how do you feel about the whole Scandal
thing the whole what really
Scandal what is that I'm wearing what is
it send it to Daryl the the the Tom
sandal okay don't don't get mad at me I
don't know oh I'm not mad um Tom sandal
he's on a a show called uh Vander pump
Vander pump rules well Vander pump rules
uh I know that show I don't watch it
though did he do something bad he uh he
uh had sex with Rael how old she she
like young no yeah she is young but
that's not the problem not too young her
his girlfriend that was her best friend
okay so he he cheated on his girlfriend
with her best friend yeah that's a bad
move yeah okay that's a positive take
unless if you're Mormon you know then it
doesn't matter as much
okay so jacine when I meet a girl from
Utah I go I married two of your sisters
last week I don't know if you know oh my
God so it's Jaclyn like you know you you
you had to throw that story had to think
about what's the Mormon what's the
Mormon girl isn't that isn't that the
the mommy uh vlogger yeah I think she's
open game to make fun of she just got in
trouble what's her name Frank Frank
Frankie uh no you know about that the
the girl so there was a a a family
vlogger okay you know and she got she
just got arrested because they found one
of the children Ru Ruby Frank what did
she do though she I don't know what she
did it's what she did child abuse yeah
family vlogger Ruby Frank arrested on
suspicion of aggravated child abuse they
found one of the children emaciated and
with duct tape why what what why would
you do that so you're against that well
that's awful like I have two kids like
I'm want to not feed my kid what's wrong
with the person and you wouldn't duct
tape them no okay just one and know no I
mean that's ridiculously crazy what H
what ended up happening did they take
she's going to jail but I think that
the she from Utah oh okay yeah I was
just trying to keep
a a clear path like a straight path
what's another uh internet thing that we
were gonna that I was going to talk
about there's Scandal there's oh uh
Colleen Ballinger they were talking
about that yesterday in fact you
interviewed her great uh that that JoJo
girl you were Ethan and I were like boy
you asked every question right and what
do you think of that what the whole
thing the Coline ballot well I watched
the whole thing what I said to Ethan is
I think that the girl was 12 and she was
treated really nice by that girl Colleen
so you know she likes her as a person
and um she's stuck up her because she's
loyal and likes her now I don't know
what happen behind on the scenes but you
when you're very young you're
impressionable and when people old are
nice to you and you know there's a maybe
a loyalty thing but you don't know what
happened behind the scenes with those
two does that sound that was my take on
because uh Ethan talked about that like
40 minutes yesterday oh did he yeah and
you are wonderful on your interviewing
skills me and Ethan could believe like
you ask all the right questions and
everything he's learned since uh his
sand ofal I interview Tom sand I was the
only person you you learned after you
did a different one you mean yeah I got
in trouble Lear his inter his interview
skills on that one we're bad below
subpar how how long have you been doing
your podcast is it new you also had a
talk show years I've had a talk show
I've been in the business for a long
time I don't do homework I've done more
homework you don't do homework so you
didn't know no I've done more homework
of uh about uh Jimmy Lee the Jersey
Outlaw than I did about Tom sandal and
Scandal do I rate do I actually you do I
love comedy Uncle Howe oh I have another
Scandal that's going on that maybe we
could have his take on okay go ahead mil
and Ashton oh yeah think of that Ashton
Kutcher so what's tell me oh you don't
know you're on the internet maybe not
this he's on the web not the world Wide
Web okay yeah Spider-Man's on the
worldwide web but I'm not see what he
did there mhm I get it I got it
now now Ashton Kutcher and Mila Kunis
were uh sticking up for the character of
uh Danny
Masterson okay and Danny Masterson was
convicted of rape for two women and
those two celebrities were sticking up
for him because they were that's stupid
they were friends and were the same show
so is the guy Danny masteron was it did
he do it yeah and he's been put away for
he put away for they're out right dumb
that's just dumb okay for for somebody
doing something that bad I'm glad we
could get all these takes from you yeah
but you know what without knowing about
it I think that you people are going to
and you will comment that you're you're
you're landing on the right
side
[Music]
n